bonjour david zobda bonjourbonjour mardi
1er et bonjour à tous les martiniquais
qui nous écoutent secrétaire national de
bâtir le pays martinique et bâtir qui
organisera donc un congrès refondateur
au mois de mars prochain
refondateurs il était temps pourquoi
faut-il refonder david zobda mais il y
faut refonder parce que tout parti
politique qui est un organe vivant qui
doit s'adapter aux réalités à la fois
politique économique et sociale du pays
et il faut de manière très régulière que
congrès soit organisé d'abord parce que
l'objet même du congrès s'est fixé ou
peut-être et adapter les statuts
règlement à la réalité du pays sur le
monde change autour de nous vous ne
resterez la 118 ensuite congrès a aussi
pour vocation de redéfinir la ligne
idéologique de parti politique et ses
principaux mots d'ordre et enfin un
congrès a pour vocation de mettre en
place une nouvelle équipe dirigeante
pont pour pour ce parti c'est ce que
nous avons l'intention face et déjà
renouvellement pour ne pas être frappés
comme d'autres de d'immobilisme non il
s'agit pas de ça ne sont pas dans cette
logique là nous savons simplement que
l'année 2018 sera brownie d'un est
extrêmement importante en une année
charnière donc il faut que l'on se
prépare tente à la ville du lamentin cac
à bâtir il faut qu'on se prive pas et
qu'on puisse ressouder les équipes
motivées remettra en route la machine
partir sur d'autres perspectives vous
savez un parti politique s'il n'anticipe
pas s'il ne perçoit pas ce qui convient
de faire pour la société martiniquaise
d'une manière générale ben il va rester
d'alinéa ci sera dépassée par les
événements que vous donnez un autre a
pas du tout pas du tout je parlais de
bâtir je parlais d'une manière générale
de secret party peut envisager
maintenant nous sommes dans cette
logique là à bâtir et nous pensons qu'il
faut anticiper qu'il faut prendre les
devants et qu'il faut avoir une vision
tout ce que l'on souhaite d'abord pour
le maintien ensuite pour la martinique
alors pourquoi 2018 seraient davantage
une année charnière que 2010 est parce
qu il y ait des élections de 2017 était
très chargé
je vous apprends rien nous avons eu un
renouvellement complet de l'échelon
national d'abord avec le pouvoir
exécutif qui a changé il n'a pas échappé
que monsieur ma couette au pouvoir nous
a pas non plus échapper que nous avons
élections législatives et des élections
sénatoriales à dire le pouvoir
législatif aussi a changé et on voit
bien que dans la reconfiguration du
paysage politique à l'échelon français
comme à l'échelon martiniquais il y a
beaucoup de choses qui bougent et sont
en train de se préparer
peut-être des des modifications en
profondeur la manière de faire de la
politique ici en martinique avec des
peut-être des mouvements qui vont qui
vont s'opérer peut-être aussi le départ
de certains grands leaders martinique
hier ça montre qu'ils vont dire ça vaut
par exemple et rencontrer l'envisager
pour devoir 18,6 termine ce que je dis
entre autres
mais on voit bien qu'il y à des
modifications en profondeur du paysage
politique martiniquais qui vont arriver
qui vont nécessairement impacté
élections 2020 et plus encore celle de
2021 alors je reviens pierre samot il
nous reste par exemple il pourrait par
exemple laisser la mairie avant 2021
date des prochaines élections
municipales
rendez-vous à poser la question alors
que vous connaissez déjà la réponse ce
n'est plus un secret de polichinelle je
n'ai déjà dit ici puis à samo l'a déjà
dit lui même c'est devant d'une manière
très publique puissamment a indiqué
qu'en 2018 il allait se retirer des
responsabilités municipales pour se
consacrer pour consacrer les dés les
séjours à venir à sa famille qui n'a pas
vu grandir je l'utilisais ses propres
mots il est très clair que nous
aborderons donc à 2018
une étape différente de la vie publique
municipale et enfin david zobda sera mr
d'une âme en attaque david zobda
n'amenez pas pressés vous dites enfin
vous le dites pour vous mais vous savez
je l'ait déjà tous il qualifie de kelly
qui voulait pas du calife à la place du
calife
moi je j'ai appris une chose en
politique c'est que le nez première
vertu que tout homme politique doit
avancer la patience
comme audiard yole vaut mieux attendre
sa guitare vient pas achalés je n'ai
rien à moi j'assume les responsabilités
à la mairie du lamentin
je suis premier adjoint depuis de
l'année 2012 auparavant de 2008 à 2012
j'étais troisième adjoint je crois que
personne n'a redire sur la qualité de
service la ville de la manche cette mane
qui devenu d'imiter la personne sur ma
loyauté vis-à-vis des pièces à moins de
la stratégie de la politique de matières
bio art unique vous êtes manet fort
heureusement de bâtir le pays martinique
et maintenant député de la martinique et
c'est très bien
écoutez nous avons besoin d'une députée
nous avons besoin d'avoir au relais
national la martinique en a aussi besoin
donc pour nous le la configuration
politique actuelle fait qu'un 2018 je le
répète ça sera un ami évidemment charlie
alors quels sont les enjeux pour bâtir
le pays martinique s'assurer que le
l'inventaire reste dans votre giron
politique c'est une évidence un lien est
évident en politique rien n'est évident
c'est comme un match de foot vous savez
il faut le jouer vous dire c'est facile
mais il faut jouer le match
en politique c'est pareil lien est
évident rien est acquis d'avancé il faut
travailler il faut être à l'écouté de la
population il faut apporter un projet
qui correspond aux aspirations du plus
grand il faut sentir un peu comment
évoluent les choses
évidemment nous souhaitons nous
présenter à l'élection municipale
prochaine et avoir de bonnes chances de
gagner
nous l'espérons maintenant et s'appuie
sur la gestion sur votre bilan de la
gestion municipale entre autres oui
s'appuyer sur le sur le bilan mais vous
savez peut-être jamais une élection avec
le bilan qu'elles sont vraies c'est de
la région auraient concernant la gestion
municipale des élèves de la ctm nous a
bien montré combien passion au bilan
mais sur peut-être projet dès lors que
le projet et autres au centre du débat
ce qui n'a pas été le cas pour la cdm
mais nous pensons que les électeurs aux
municipalités sont très attentifs à ce
qu'on va leur proposant à la gestion
municipale
alors quels sont les points faibles
selon vous à améliorer d'ici 2026 en ce
qui concerne la gestion municipale par
bâtir le pays bâti goûter il y un
certain nombre de points qui qui
reviennent et qui sont récurrents
d'ailleurs
président macron devra annoncer au maire
aujourd'hui très certainement un certain
nombre de dispositions à venir
concernant la gestion des municipalités
puisque vous savez que il y à un grave
problème financier dans les
municipalités d'une manière globale qui
crie l'année satisfaction de la
population évidemment parce que les
mères n'ont plus les moyens de mettre à
bien leur projet donc évidemment la
ville du lamentin comme toutes les
villes de france et de martinique est
touché par cette difficulté financière
il y a peut être aussi chez nous à la
menthe et en particulier à arnaud
dialogue avec l'ensemble des agents de
la ville pour que ceux ci soient mieux
appliquées mieux qu'en phase avec le
projet politique que nous portons
je pense qu'il faut que je me consacre
entièrement à cette mission cette
mission la voix de bâtir cet ensemble
pour une martinique nouvelle cela reste
une évidence mais c'est évident pour
personne je voulais dit tout à l'heure
vous avez écouté ce que j'ai dit il y
aura très certainement une
bouleversement arrivée qui arrivera pour
la politique ne se fait plus comme il se
faisait auparavant vous avez noté qu'il
y à des bouleversements idéologique on
ne pourra plus d'idéologie
on parle plus de caen douanes gauche ça
a beaucoup évolué alors est-ce qu'on va
se retrouver avec une alliance autour de
valeurs politiques
deux mondes cachés chan passent ou ou
bien je pense pas qu'on sera dans cette
logique là vous savez c'est de plus en
plus décrié je pense que ceux qui
viennent pour un poste seront vite
éliminés mais je veux dire que on
pourrait aussi imaginer qu'une autre
alliance se fasse à partir de projets ou
de programmes communs reprend des vieux
mot mais en des termes d'actualité ça
positionne un peu l'alliance sur un
autre axe un autre angle on a on a vu
avec la gronde monte on ne sait toujours
pas si des de droite ou de gauche que la
politique ne se fait pas ne se ferait
plus strictement sur un sens idéologique
claire mais plutôt sur des perspectives
rcp sont un peu différentes de ce qui
pourrait rassembler désormais deux
femmes qu'est ce qui doit être le
leitmotiv de partis politiques d'une
formation comme la vôtre c'est apprendre
à gérer financièrement de l'activité
c'est ce que reprochent les ce qu'ont
reproché les adversaires d'ensemble pour
une martinique nouvelle tout côté yopa
coc déficit tueur habitait au monde
mattie nicklas sabbagh équipe qui a fait
tant de la fei ses opacités ces
magouilles vous vous posez vous élever
contre ça c'est l'image que
malheureusement la population à des
déformations politique je crois que vous
étiez en train de parler de la situation
actuelle la ctm j'ai dû me tromper mais
le dessin que vous faisiez correspondait
parfaitement à la situation actuelle
on a surtout dit cette motion du parti
nouvelle lors des élections de 2015
oui mais on revient bien à la situation
actuelle avec l'autorité avec le
sectarisme avec l'opacité avec bon
toutou le cortège est ce que vous
connaissez donc s'applique à tout le
monde vous êtes vous en êtes vous même
vous êtes vous même une victime a donc
bien innocente enfin bref c'est une
femme exploiter c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui pour parler un peu plus
sérieusement la classe politique d'une
manière générale est décrit au sein de
la population parce que l'image que nous
envoyons n'est pas une image
satisfaisante
et n'allez pas parce que nous sommes
souvent dans des conflits politiques et
l'opinion publique se dit mais quand
est-ce qu'ils vont vraiment travailler
pour l'intérêt général de la population
donc je pose donc la question de savoir
comment un parti politique peut orienter
sa réflexion mais nous pensions que
parti politique doit affirmer si je
crois pour la société martiniquaise et
porter un vrai projet pour la martinique
c'est à ça que la refonte de bâtir un
ciel bien merci
vous êtes cet international de bâtir le
pays martinique merci beaucoup
[Musique]